foreign
Field Missouri what's up Chris how we
doing
hey man
um before I start I just wanted to say
thank you to you guys and everybody at
Ramsey Solutions
um since I was younger you got a really
positive impact on me and my financial
decision so cool I just want to say for
that well thanks brother I appreciate it
man
um I think it would be important just to
give you guys a little bit of context on
me and just my background before I ask
my questions so um basically I've always
been really good with my money over a
few years I was able to save up like 50
um 40 000 of it was in my savings and
then 10 000 of it I had invested in
mutual funds
um I also am going to school
I like to say better than debt free
because I'm going totally free good for
you that's awesome scholarships and a
work study and stuff like that um
so with that though
um
during uh all of that time that I was
accumulating those funds I was in an
abusive relationship
um pretty much like anything negative
you could think of uh I'm sorry
she dished all that out so it uh it kind
of messed me up and when I was finally
able to get out of it
um as a way of coping I guess I started
spending my money on a lot of stuff
um
sorry
um you're all right
over like maybe eight months now I've
totally drained
all my savings and uh I've pulled out
all my investments and I've just spent
it all crap and um
I probably only have like I don't know
maybe a little under two thousand
dollars now okay uh
so I just I don't really know where to
go from here because my plan originally
was once I get my bachelor's
um
you know the deal that I kind of have
with my parents is like once I'm done
with college and I'm out of the house
and that's just what it is
um and I was going to go to grad school
and everything but
I'm just not really sure how
to like go about doing that and just
what to do financially anymore
so I think
um you know Dave's been saying for years
your money is just a reflection of
what's going on in your heart and mind
and soul in life
and so right now I want to move the
money conversation over it's a big it's
a big neon sign
letting you know that you're not all
right right now
and I want to tell you
having sat with people I can't count how
many people I've sat across the table
with or sat next to
who are trying to figure out who they
are after leaving an abusive
relationship
and the chaos of I still love that
person but that person deeply hurt me in
a number of different ways I lost part
of myself and I don't even know what
that means and how to get that back all
of that stuff is all chaotic in a mess
and
yeah man you you got out your spending
card and went went bananas what I would
tell you is the sun came up today right
that's true yeah you got 2 000 bucks
and I don't want to minimize you're
going to have some grief and you're
probably going to have some uh
resentment you're gonna have all that
stuff all those feelings dude listen to
me they're right they're fine they're
good
they're right
the only thing you can do from this
moment forward
you can't go back and edit sentences
that have already been written they got
a period at the end of them
you were in love with somebody that
hurts you deeply you broke up
you've spent forty eight thousand
dollars in a spending spree to wallpaper
over depression and grief and sadness
and here you are
and the things you told us leading up to
those moments tell me that you are a
strong kid and that you're a driven guy
and you have accomplished a ton we we
very few of the adults that call into
this show have fifty thousand dollars
access fifty thousand dollars cash my
brother very few people call in and say
hey I figured out how to do college for
free
and so you had a plan and that plan is
going to be different now you had a plan
you're just gonna Waltz into grad school
into your next job because you had a big
nest egg well you don't have that
anymore so cool
nothing about what you've told me
suggests that you suddenly have lost the
ability to work really hard because I
know that's who you are and nothing
you've told me says suddenly you're dumb
because you're not
what you have told me is you're going to
have to spend some see a season grieving
this you're gonna have to go spend some
time with a counselor
okay and I would tell you that if you
were my best friend or you're my brother
okay okay and you're gonna spend some
time healing and you're gonna spend some
time here's the here's the uncomfortable
truth about abusive relationships that
people often don't hear it's real easy
to be on the outside of that and to
demonize the abuser what people often
fail to take into account is the person
being abused loses trust in themself I
don't even trust me anymore and now
you've got 48 000 reasons to further not
trust you right
what you're gonna have to do is learn to
build trust in Chris again
that's just going to take some practice
my man
okay okay
yeah
so here's the deal I want you to hang on
the line here are you you're still in
school right
yeah I I got a year left okay here's why
that's Phenom that's fantastic I'm so
happy because that means you have access
to a student Counseling Center that's
going to be outstanding and in a time
when um it's very hard to just call a
therapist off the street and get an
appointment you're going to be able to
do that so I want you to make that call
today in exchange for making that call
um we're gonna send you can Coleman's
get clear assessment we're going to send
you his book paycheck to purpose and I'm
going to send you my book own your past
change your future
and that my whole book is what happens
when you are sitting down you realize
you're an ash and how do you take that
next step out okay I'm grateful for the
call man and we love you and we'll help
you every step of the way here I just
need you to hear me say you're not
broken you're not dysfunctional you
didn't do anything wrong I mean you blew
a bunch of money and I would laugh with
you in high five if we're sitting at the
table
um and also I don't believe Jay I don't
believe in the phrase too soon that's
just kind of me but I I'd high five of
you and then we would get on with okay
what comes next but you got some healing
to do oh yeah
tough
I think you covered it I'm not gonna add
or take away
how I'm trying to think of how I've
wrestled with moments of my life Jade
when I've just flat out
set my values on fire or I've flat out
done something I said I wasn't gonna do
or I've spent my time poking my finger
at people who do things and then all of
a sudden I look up six months later and
I'm that guy now right right you know
it's tough I was sitting here trying to
think of a similar situation like when
have I been there like what have I and
it's you can really live in the past and
wallow in like man what I did I spent
forty eight thousand dollars how could I
have done that but then it's like what
are you gonna do next
and I I I think as a as a culture we
have two narratives one is you're always
going to be the worst thing you you've
ever done the worst thing ever happened
you're always gonna be the dumbest thing
you've ever done and then the other one
is if you have feelings and you're a
coward and a wimp and you're weak you
just suck it up and grind it and I think
that's nonsense I think the world is
desperate for a new Third Way which is
we're gonna spend some time feeling sad
and we're gonna have some grief
um you went through hell
and you did some dumb stuff yeah let's
just acknowledge it yeah and then
we're gonna get the right people around
us and because we can't do it alone we
got the right people around us and then
we're going to take the next crooked
wobbly step forward to wherever it is
we're going right yeah progress not
necessarily Perfection nobody's out here
doing things perfect we're all just
trying to
just trying to make some kind of
progress forward right I mean George
Campbell tells us he's perfect his hair
is perfect his hair is perfect it's high
it's high and tight well you should see
the hair dryer he has back there I've
never seen it it's the he actually
converted an old air conditioner
um it's really an extraordinary
I need to get on that then well they
have a special plug in there it's like a
220. it's incredible